brought to you by rise of the Tomb
Raider 20 years celebration now
available on ps4 birthday celebrations
are in order as Tomb Raider is turning
20 this year damn Lara what is your
secret anyway this week in 10 minutes is
brought to you by rise of the Tomb
Raider
which is now available on ps4 and so to
celebrate 20 years of Croft here's a few
things you probably didn't know about
Tomb Raider it's no secret that a big
influence for Tomb Raider was
whip-wielding snake hating Indiana Jones
and that Lara was originally going to be
male
dr. Jones makes a couple of cameos in
the Tomb Raider series in the first game
the Ark of the Covenant is just casually
hanging out in the hallway of Croft
Manor because where better to store it
but it seems like the developers were
determined to give poor Indy grisly ends
in the last revelation you can find his
skeleton lying in a spike trap and in
Anniversary his infamous hat and whip a
squished against the side of a boulder
in the Peru level ouch speaking of sexy
archaeologist slash treasure hunters
Nathan Drake makes a surprise appearance
in temple of Osiris sadly we didn't get
any of his wisecracks or handsome mush
because he is dead on the ground but I'd
recognize that braces dirty shirt and
chinos combo anywhere some of gaming's
best Easter eggs come from the
communities and when Tomb Raider fans
noticed a red crab in a trailer for the
2013 reboot they of course gave it an
adorable name beefy in the final game if
you shoot any crab on shipwreck beach
you get the hidden achievement crab
cakes with the description
fefe the crab killed r.i.p Fifi but
hello five gamerscore the original Tomb
Raider was packed full of cheat codes to
help you skip levels become invincible
and get infinite ammo enter the level
skip code from Tomb Raider 1 incorrectly
into Tomb Raider 2 would cause Lara to
explode so the developers didn't mind
you cheating just as long as you do it
properly and finally not only was Lara
originally conceived as a male she was
later developed into the South American
Laura Cruz however at this time core
designs parent company had been acquired
by idose who wanted a more UK friendly
name so the developers took to the Derby
phonebook for inspiration
now alphabetically speaking Croft is of
course near cruise and with her new name
they turned her into an English
aristocrat Acrobat and archaeologist and
that's how Lara Croft was born so hope
you enjoyed your trip down memory slash
trivia Lane make sure to join me this
Friday for reality check where I'll be
exploring what would actually happen if
you were to lock your elderly Butler in
a freezer come on we all did it anyway
in the meantime you can find me on
Twitter at Lucy James games and for more
videos like this one make sure to LIKE
and subscribe to GameSpot
you